[Applause]
god I'm amazing the way these people
would tell it I am absolutely amazing
thank you so much Christian I'd simply
like to say it's about time ladies and
gentlemen it's about time it's about
space it's about a lot of people in the
strangest to please from a rolling hills
of plains of North America to the
mountains of Appalachia from the desert
beauty of Navajo been a nation to the
gritty streets of Los Angeles and the
soundstages of Hollywood we're wearing
motion picture wardrobe it's been a wild
and wonderful ride and I'm really proud
to be here tonight as the first
indigenous Native American to receive an
Academy Award
for a body of work
for a body of work and I won't say how
long it's taken me to do this I can only
say that the journey has been peopled by
many from grips and electricians to
focus pullers on camera crews and
lighting experts Transpo makeup wardrobe
effects greens set decorator
construction workers working alongside
actors directors background people and
producers and yes Studios with our ever
important business offices within them I
must say I had the most wonderful and
efficient team of managers and agents in
the persons of Alexa Pegula's Michael
black from micro black management
Melissa farmer from domain agency and
they relieve me of my prime of the
process of making the deal yeah so yeah
yeah I could still be available yeah now
my mini thinks that I offered tonight
her heartfelt sincere to the governors
of the Academy and especially former
Governor Gregory Nava and his beautiful
wife Barbara for nominating me in the
first place
and explaining to me the intricacies and
the meaning of this particular award
it's a total and humbling honor to
receive an award for doing something I
love to do and comparatively speaking
started late in life but a who's
counting right
I've been blessed really blessed by
support for my efforts on many fronts
from my parents Maggie who you saw in
the late and estudio colors Ville
Oklahoma two of my children Leah and :
who are here with us tonight
two more adieu studi My partner and wife
of 30-plus years who through just a bit
unlike my parents who did blink a bit
one tort once or twice whenever I told
him my decision to move out to LA to
become an actor Mora has always had the
why not attitude and that and that that
let's just do it kind of philosophy of
getting down to word getting out to work
and planning the next step of furthering
a career and finding the next job or
creating your own work whether in film
stage TV Hey
you know I mean an act has got to keep
working right now I was fortunate to
have come to Hollywood at a time when
Native Americans were a subject of
interest in the film business you know
it comes and goes from yeah from my my
commercial film debut in the one indie
film called powwow highway hey okay got
a stir and it starred Gary Pharma my
good friend and it was directed by Santa
Fe my Santa Fe neighbor Jonathan wax to
my most recent stint in front of the
camera for the film hostile started
Christian bill rosemon hi Coriana
Kilcher and myself it was directed by
Scott Cooper and produced by John lesser
I'd hoped I had hoped I would see them
tonight but well but I'm forever
grateful for the many casting directors
I've worked with over the years because
you know without them actually directing
the process of casting I don't think I
would be here in front of you tonight
and I think you all I thank you very
much for your work
Dances with Wolves was and is probably
the film that got me started in the
business you know luckily there was a
character with no actual name known only
as the toughest pawnee was noticed by
audiences and filmmakers alike and I
believe the Pawnee even appreciated it
and for that I have of course Kevin
Costner to thank for that and I thank
you Kevin and I'm especially honored
tonight to have at my table Michael Mann
Michael directed me in two of his many
films both last of the mohicans and heat
milestones milestones in my career and
one as you know the angry Magua of last
Mohicans and a character called castles
of heat castles allowed me to go beyond
the leather and feathers of period drama
to an ethnic non specific role played
out in the dark underbelly of
contemporary society was that a mouthful
or why thank you Michael
thank you very much we should do another
one after you get finished that with
that one no another tee time hitter for
me was the incomparable director Walter
Hill who took a chance Walter Hill
Walter took a chance on an unknown
fractal unknown to to play the title
role of Geronimo among a huge cast of a
list actors likes of Gene Hackman Robert
Duvall and Walter
also we shot a film a boxing film in
prison and I also considered this role
kind of ethnically nonspecific as well
undisputed was a who to shoot in prison
so I think Walter for that so like these
guys that I just named are the guys who
more or less made me you know but the
thing about it is while I thank everyone
for all of these things I of course have
to say that I put in some effort as well
in any case I started working a lot
after these films they they afforded me
the opportunity to find work in
subsequent films like the highest box
office movie of its time avatar you
heard of it was created and directed by
James Cameron and produced by John
Landale and I think those guys now while
I've had you know good luck to be in
blockbuster movies important films over
the years I'm just as proud if not more
to have worked with writers directors
and producers of many independent films
that have gone on to like really have
legs of their own and working I also
worked in the fast developing Native
Americans fear of filmmaking with
director producer Georgina lightning
with her film older than America
and with director Chris Ayer for for his
film edge of America I guess we kind of
had this thing about America and while I
refuse to call the only good Indian my
personal favorite I will call it my
favorite film directed by Kevin Willmott
of black clansmen Fame guy Thank You
Georgina Chris and Kevin we should make
some more so in closing I'd like to
thank each and every actor I have ever
worked with whether you like me or not
from my very first paying gig at
American Indian Theatre Company in Tulsa
Oklahoma to the recently thank you to
the recently completed Western called
badlands set to open November 1 and last
but certainly not the least I've run a a
big shout out to the fans and followers
and shows social media that and
moviegoers that make all of this
possible for us but don't whatever Allah
al aliy steel or today's gold is a lock
year
TJ what o is on your say who it is Allah
Allah
is he your ski is your ski just Anna
what on a layer Lee Hailey's do well
[Applause]